47 seconds of logos also DC Comics used
to one to save the world narration
question for the security personnel if
you're taking this much care to lock
this briefcase away in the armored truck
why on Batman's blue earth did you park
this far away from your entry point
seriously look at the shot from above
here's the van here's the entry point
just put on a fake beak and take a seat
in the triangle pond because you just
made yourself a sitting duck why is her
main work desk directly in the corner of
all the fabulous artifacts she and the
museum have collected this is like the
bank manager having his office inside
the safe deposit box vault
Jesus Christ this movie's gonna take me
all the way back to wonder little girl
times CGI Asgard and CGI and Abu got
nothing on CGI Wonder Woman place also
couldn't the movie have started here
little girl running in an ancient city
probably Wonder Woman but I'm intrigued
enough to pay close attention I mean why
do we need the opening intro of her in
present day being a curator
I thought I'd seen enough from the Zack
Snyder school of slow-mo badassery but
holy did you just see that 10-foot
spinning flip sword toss that MO could
never be too slow
random daytime armadillo is random also
what is it with DC superheroes and
childhoods other than the very
forgettable daredevil but Marvel movies
can you think of that spend time on the
heroes childhood anyone Bueller and yet
in the DC world Superman Batman and now
Wonder Woman we always have to have a
childhood opening our flashback long ago
help me understand this bedtime book is
it just the one picture is it Potter
style coming to life for Diana also
three full minutes a bedtime story
exposition who wouldn't I prayed will
never be called to arms classic not
answering the question after aging from
7 to 13 and presumably training with
Robin Wright for the whole time
finally her mother catches her training
my point is the movie chose a poor time
to rapidly age up diana only to then
introduce this cut by mom seen mom was
asleep at the wheel four years before
this girl will train her harder than any
amazon before her whoa she just a 180
faster and more flawlessly than that red
headed snowboard guy everybody loved ten
years ago she must never know what the
truth about what she is or how she came
to be meaning she will definitely know
that soon in this movie Diana went from
7 years old the 13 to however old she
can be with gal gadot still pulling it
off
guessing early twenties this movie is
doing some random time jumps you're
stronger than I am
again hey everybody Morpheus is fighting
me I mean princess Buttercup is fighting
Diana this asshole crash-lands is world
war one plane in a mythical basically
non-existent land but thankfully for him
there was a brave local rebellious
princess ex machina watching the show at
that very moment convenient playing
pieces convenient if this is where the
plane breaks through and this is where
it lands unless Wonder Woman javelin to
piece of the plane about 300 feet there
is no way this plane part would be
floating here this soon after if
wherever the Diana and her kin live is
this easily infiltrated then it was
never really hitting at all and I'm
shocked no one prior to world war 1 even
accidentally found this cloaked paradise
like Magellan or Vasco da Gama's some
also exactly what good is this hiding
field if you can actually see things
through it
Seuss needs to up his camouflage game
discount From Here to Eternity how did
these arrows all get lit so fast and
honestly if you're firing out into the
ocean does it even help the movie will
go out of its way later to show how much
they know about the outside world but
they're about to fire flaming arrows at
an armored German naval division there
was no way this Archer in this bowl
should be moving at the same speed
that's neither a super slow bullet that
poses a no danger or that Archer is
swinging at about 700 miles an hour
Wow auntie auntie Opie's got skills
we've seen before
Legolas would definitely swipe right is
what I'm saying no no my mentors death
motivates protagonist cliche somehow
these ladies with fire arrows defeated a
German naval battalion and somehow that
German destroyer we saw earlier played
no part in this battle and I guess it
just disappeared where was the firepower
you know but there no he fought at my
side against the UM you mean hit by your
side from the invaders right general
Ludendorff exposition bylaw so why would
any military in any war conduct this
kind of experiment in full view of the
general officers I mean I guess she's a
psychopath but that's just a waste of a
good test subject right there this plane
is airborne in about four seconds after
traveling 50 feet I'm not saying you
need a fast and furious length runway to
get airborne but I'm pretty sure even
the strongest dose of aviation viagra
won't get it up that quick even though
Steve not Rogers blew the fuck out of
this base the Germans still managed to
be right behind him when he approached
Wonder Woman land would you say you're a
typical example of your sex
boobies got dick jokes yo good thing
it's still ticking you let this little
thing tell you what to do we are still
talking about the walnuts right deep
within the Amazonian jungle there exists
a species of elk so stupid and so
unevolved that even the most primitive
of weapons can bring her down why is
this here that's outfit oh this whole
thing I just found it hanging in the
middle of a room while I was stealing
several priceless weapons that were
unguarded and it happened to not only
fit me perfectly but be colored
completely different than anything else
the other Amazonian women where you like
it huh I know or at least I know I
cannot stop you I just wrote in here in
the middle of the night with a dozen of
my warriors to say goodbye apparently
you have been my greatest love today you
know where my greatest sorrow thanks for
the vote of confidence so the ship will
just sail itself then is it a Tesla like
the original Tesla if you never met a
man before then what about your father I
had no father
my mother has sculpted me from clay and
I was brought to life by Zeus this is
the DCE you essentially rolling the
Greek gods into actual reality and that
is just kooky enough to deserve mention
think about that Greek gods from
mythology actually exist in the DCE
Hades might be a villain one day he'll
Ares is
literally the villain of this movie
something did come to me last night a
different type of gas for you to restore
your strength let's test it right now on
you without any further research for all
it came to me last night which was hours
ago I've had hours to perfect and test
it on animals and let's do this now wait
a second movie you've established that
Diana has been educated in the languages
and customs of humans across the world
and even read all 12 volumes of some
academic porn encyclopedia she doesn't
know what holding hands is she can't
people with worldly wise and a fish out
of water at the same time no one will be
seated during the Princess Diaries
portion of the movie she's trying you're
not fit number 226 you a movie I
understand how time works you
over-exaggerated this joke by a factor
of 10 Wonder Woman can now graduate with
honors from the Clark Kent School
disguisting yet release specs suddenly
she's not the most beautiful woman
you've ever seen see the secretary here
would be excellent at cinemasins
please put the sword down Lana how did
she pull it out and walk here without
everyone else in the store freaking the
out they're all acting like they're
seeing a guy with a mohawk when in
reality what they're seeing is 50 times
more rare and scary this is the most
telegraphed head button all of movie
dome series question two the bracelets
act like bullet magnets or are these
morons repeatedly firing at her at
shoulder level
watching her block every shot with no
one thinking to shoot her in the goddamn
foot and in further intelligence just
moments earlier this room of sexist
moustaches guffaw Diana out of the room
but now she's just moseying around as
they discuss war intelligence she opens
the book to the middle and miraculously
reads about the very gas Steve saw
during his mission and he goes sir that
is the evidence we need and no one in
the room gives any more thought to any
of the other military secrets and
horrifying signs that might also be in
that notebook beyond the money no to
signor Giovanni it's a different story
Sameer loses interest in the job and
goes back to his excessive fondness for
Diana this is what I call gal gadot d
charming ed - he could run the mission
from my office you run either Melissa
McCarthy turning down this role or the
character description was literally act
like Melissa McCarthy there's enough
head a few days a few days what room and
board weapons they need driving people
to get them across the border
the Irish sniper guys beer budget alone
is probably more than what's in that
envelope also thank God he knows exactly
which pub the hooligans Steve might
recruit for his illegal mission hang out
in either that or there's only one pub
in England which we all know a true
we deserve I have no idea where they are
right now enemy territory or friendly
but on a covert non-sanctioned secret
spy mission to end the war is a huge
open flame and copious drinking really
why's nowhere better to be than in a war
where you don't take a side at least
here I'm free sure I understand I'm not
wanting to be in the US but why not
Canada or Mexico
there's no man's land diana means no man
can cross but she's not a minute let's
go she's taking all the fire because
she's currently the only target get the
Germans a few more targets and I bet
some of them start taking fire but
whatever it's still not sure her
bracelets aren't bullet magnets so this
is awesome and also if I'm being honest
a bit unrealistic I mean I know Diana is
quick at blocking bullets and all but
with this much automatic fire if she's
not completely behind that shield she's
taking some led to the legs for sure I
know you can't see in there but we can
all assume this is a stormtrooper right
I mean these shots are so off Wonder
Woman gets a chance to superhero pose
twice before even addressing it movie
takes great pains to show us that
Charlie has lost his ability to shoot
and never pays it off with any kind of
redemption poor charlie I like how Steve
and this movie thought Wonder Woman
needed a boost to make this jump I know
you can't speak Flemish so let me
interpret they are saying the team in
which she purposely destroyed our temple
she is here to eat our souls
well at least they should be saying that
I love acting I don't want to be a
soldier
he's lucky indeed if it wasn't already
obvious to you that David Thewlis his
character was evil this please pay
attention now focus change by the camera
is here to hold your hand through the
foreshadowing these folks are happy the
Germans are gone for sure but they
witnessed a handful of legit miracles
today and this seems like more of a Suzy
got married again Bloc Party you did
this wait did off it was all you and you
know it Jesus she came here in thanks so
movie has time for this as does the war
and the secret mission to find and
destroy the gas weapon before the
Germans can use it you saw it I've been
out here
the way she tossed at the machine-gun
nest the way she took out that towel why
the bystanders talk about superheroes so
casually in these movies she jumped 80
feet in the air for pete's sake she
freaking tossed a tank forget trying to
decide if what she says is true how are
you not either questioning your sanity
or worshipping her as a god by now so
for this gag to work it needs to be
common for German officers to speak
English maybe it was and yes he's
technically talking to his driver here
but this is 1918 I'm pretty sure anyone
driving German officers for a living is
speaking German not English and even his
driver is speaking English to the German
soldier guard
what could Chris Pine do a German accent
but not learn to speak two lines of
actual German don't worry about it we
all know they'll let you in anyway
because it says so in the script what
I'm more concerned about is how they
don't recognize Steve those guys on the
street in England certainly knew him by
sight shouldn't he be on Germany's most
wanted by now as if it wasn't convenient
enough that this right-sized attendee
happened to get stopped right here now
she's going to walk straight into the
woods at the exact place diana is
waiting I might as well have had the
dress fall from the sky who are you man
who'd show you appreciation and genius
like yourself dessert Steve makes a huge
gamble that she feels unappreciated and
of course he's right because movie last
we left Diana she was on the side of the
road sizing up that blue dress so what
happened next
certainly the driver would have noticed
a passenger switch or a missing
passenger and what about her invite
could she leave the former dress
occupant unconscious and undressed by
the side of the road that's Dirty Diana
wow what a beautiful shoulder blade back
broach thing that looks nothing like the
hilt of a sword you were wearing tonight
Diana shoulder back brooches are a thing
right enjoying the party
English the official language of World
War one Germany keep in mind that diana
has proven to be fluent in many dozens
of languages and I'm sure German is one
of them but apparently at the halfway
point of the film the studio ran out of
dialect trainer money or something for
the record she spends a lot of time
dancing with the guy she's here to kill
just letting him rant
[Music]
gasps hmm maybe last night's snowfall
dance and drunk athon not to mention the
implied boning were ultimately a huge
waste of time considering you miss
stopping the gas by literally minutes so
she had her Under Armour on that whole
time under that thin blue dress and
Ludendorff couldn't feel it because what
is it with this movie and just assuming
Diane is invincible not saying she
couldn't survive this lethal gas I'm
just saying we haven't been given any
reason to believe she would and more
importantly neither is she well here's
another literal machine delivered by the
hand of God what luck so not only can
she deflect bullets but she can direct
them with pinpoint accuracy go drunk
moving your home King told you shock of
all shocks also let me get Ares plans
straight here spend decades as a
diplomat work his way into a cabinet
position so that he can influence a
possible armistice in order to keep a
war simmering he's a god isn't he he
does have more than the power to grow a
great mustache and be ignored a cabinet
meetings right now are gas masks a good
disguise for sneaking into a German base
manufacturing a gas for which gas masks
provide no protection like yeah it hides
her face but why would any Germans be
wearing useless gas masks in this place
well she luck in this battle I guess
nice to know you Wonder Woman unless you
discover some heretofore unknown well of
power and strength inside you here in a
few minutes I did I don't want to fight
but it is a superhero movie so let the
endless punching commence throwing a box
of grenades at a king god that explosion
conveniently blew her directly into
Steve Trevor's running path it's almost
like Ares has a sense of humor or
something this playing door opens easily
from the outside during takeoff were
they expecting a pizza delivery well I
exactly does all this God punching even
matter Diana knows at this point that
Stephen Ares are right about humans
being weak he's barely doing anything
and man is willing to go to war seems to
me no matter who wins people be people
but why if the gas is flammable and all
you have to do is make it explode why
not land the plane away from the people
and set a charge I mean it's a beautiful
sentiment at all but completely
unnecessary magically and just in time
Diana discovers a deeper well of her
power she never knew existed huzzah
whatever it is I can't no wait so she
could hear him or she couldn't or she
couldn't but now she can and remembering
or she can read lips but only after 10
minutes or so or maybe she's travelling
back in time so she can hear what he
said or maybe forget it
it doesn't matter anyway we all know
where this is headed cuz this this is
Wonder Woman this is more like Godzilla
breath here it's a good thing the movie
so clearly explain how she got these
powers what they are and how to defeat a
god that Zeus couldn't even kill where
are they holding him
we should kill him now and be done with
it
[Applause]
what the hell is this thing lieutenant
blue I wanna know this is my canoe
you're stronger than this Diana you
think that's air you're breathing now
can you get some towels for me please
I'm really losing a lot of blood
you sound like you're proving that guys
oh oh whipping is far deadlier than you
can ever imagine
I don't know I can imagine quite a bit I
am Diana of thymus Kiera daughter of
Hippolyta queen of the Amazons you
killed my father